never have I ever tried twerking do you
not working it no I've never tried it
I'm Louis yeah I'm Kevin he's the young
one well the first drink I ever had was
the night I graduated from high school
and I drove all the way to t1 and Mexico
and I had a whiskey sour and I've never
had one since that time we will be
having a drinking competition and I
think we would win oh yeah Sally now I
can fix it but today they're nice people
they're friendly but uh that doesn't win
drinking games
well you know I think our performance
was impeded by our teammates we said
what we were gonna do I said well I was
gonna cheat and then Sally played by our
own rules quite frankly are you ready
for a girl to beat you
I am wasted now
when we go back to the neighborhood
bring it no pressure no pressure oh you
wanna challenge us in beer pong game on
never have I ever sent a sext I'm
guessing that that means a text is sexy
I would really hope you've never sent a
sext because I have to teach you how to
use your phone all the time
never have I ever sharted do you know
what sharded means no yeah you don't
need to don't worry never by ever had a
one-night stand
you've never had a one-night stand
oh you that's you know but have you of
course then drink have you ever watched
porn online huh come on goodness
gracious
never have I ever punched somebody in
the face have you ever been in a fight
yes it was in a bar and the security
forces broke it up you got into a bar
fight I've been in several bar fights
wait what never have ever gotten high Bo
liar liar I'm serious I've never got not
if you smoked
you got a threat v we believed in
ourselves when the going got tough I saw
the elbow go over the table too many
times over the line we dominated we
learned something there is no such
generation gap when it comes to fun and
drinking drinking
you